and as some businesses do begin to
reopen my next guest is cautioning that
may be merely a transition month yeah
may will be a transition month as the
country begins to come back here now is
Larry Kudlow director of the US National
Economic Council so Larry you heard that
barber shop owner he seems like a really
cool guy Torian we can get back to work
safely he says and do it our own way and
I know you're a free market tear layer
that low and you love that story as much
as I do
go ahead actually I got at a I love that
guy and I'm also going to confess I had
a hair trim yesterday it's kind of a
special deal friends friends about you
know this a person but I'm not
commencing any names she got her
hairdresser to come in and open up her
barber shop so and the guy gave me a
pretty good trim I don't have much to
work with but it looks much better
because I want it to look good on the
Laura Ingram show that was a key point
and Here I am
I had no temperature this morning coming
into the White House I tested negative
last week I feel fine and I love that
guy like to meet up sometime so you know
so you're special you got a haircut the
rest of us are just we're you know we're
dealing with it now I'm just teasing but
look at me as a transition month Larry
got to get this economy going you know
where people are dying out there that
guy's that guy that was a sad be opening
to that story it's like I'm bleeding
money all right my money ain't paying
out I'm gonna get my car repossessed
that's the American understanding right
now if we don't get this thing going
I think Brian camp is gonna be a big
success story look guys I hope I totally
agree I mean you you've got to meet the
guidelines a move got good scientific
good base guidelines you got to have
your downward adjustment and infection
cases within a 14-day period
you got to observe in a he way he ran it
down pretty well you got to have the
testing you got to have the cleaning you
got to have the hand-washing and all the
rest of it you got to have the
distancing but if that is true if you
meet those criteria I think you're gonna
see a lot of states opening in the next
few weeks and I think the month of May
is going to be a terrific trend
transition month as the economy
reawakens it'll be rolling you know
phase at a time
heck twenty-six million people or 26
million people the name the last five
weeks have filed unemployment claims
sixteen percent of the whole workforce
we cannot continue that very fortunate
now if we are fortunate then you know
what the numbers will keep coming down
and people will reopen and we'll get
this economy restarted again restarted
again
well the White House is considering
apparently tonight we learn of a
liability shield that would protect
employers from lawsuits related to
coronavirus businesses say they need
this to reopen otherwise they're gonna
get slammed with the plaintiffs lawyers
lawsuits but critics say it's just going
to excuse bad work conditions unsafe
environments your response that's just
not true
I mean look it Cobin nineteen guidelines
you've got federal guidelines state
guidelines city county guidelines that's
what these stores and small businesses
they have to abide by that so if they do
then I think there should be a safe
guard around the liabilities related to
the Cova nineteen virus there should be
a safe guy I mean look it's very if you
go to a restaurant just take this
example you go to a restaurant that's
recently open the restaurant observes
all the guidelines okay every single one
of them now
unfortunately if the customer comes down
with the virus
unfortunately yeah how can you prove
necessarily that it's the restaurants
fault because this thing is highly
infectious as you know I don't think we
should open the door to a lot of false
claims by trial lawyers and others who
are always on the lookout you'll stop
the business from opening or the
business will close or they won't have
enough money to keep going because of
these lawsuits so why not have some
safeguards and by the way not just the
business but also the employees in the
business she detected from these kinds
of phony lawsuits
I think there's incredible wisdom in it
I think it has to happen
economy has to get going we have to get
back to work do it safely but let the
free market - truck will they'll
innovate and adapt better than the
government ever could have imagined
that's my view Larry thank you for
joining us really appreciate it